après l'espoir due à l'arrivée des
vaccins contre le coleader de la pénurie
les commandes des grands pays européens
se réduisent à mesure que les
laboratoires et organise leur production
pour répondre à la demande
certains comme le royaume uni semble
épargnée alors que d'autres comme la
france par exemple voient leurs
campagnes de vaccination retardée alors
comment expliquer de tels écarts ces
retards dans les vaccins qu'on promet-il
la reprise économique
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques est bon soir j'accueille
bienvenue sur mon sens est tenue à
distance toujours alors nous avions
abordé déjà la question des vaccins
jacques il ya trois semaines que révèle
la pénurie actuelle s'ils voulaient y
écrire que nous sommes maintenant dans
une situation de pénurie
il est aussi très clair que cette
situation elle découle des besoins en
millions voire en milliards de doses
pour pouvoir vacciner le plus de monde
possible et des capacités de production
des laboratoires alors derrière cela il
ya aussi la question des stratégies
d'achat des doses ces stratégies ont été
différente de pays à pays
certains ont été plus efficaces que
d'autres et puis aussi les stratégies
des laboratoires qui vont jouer beaucoup
dans ce domaine alors jacques lançon par
le commencement 1 pourquoi sommes nous
confrontés à cette situation de pénurie
de vaccins si vous voulez c'est très
simple nous avons aujourd'hui dans le
monde environ 8 milliards 4 d'habitants
si nous souhaitons que 70% soit vaccinée
ça veut dire qu'il faudra que nous
accueillons entre cinq et demi et 6
milliards d'ici la fin de l'année
autrement dit il faudra fournir entre 11
et 12 milliards de doses si on regarde
le cas de la france
bon sur la france le la même proportion
pour atteindre l'immunité vaccinale
saint pie de vacciner 45 millions de
personnes 45 millions de personnes
ça implique aussi 90 millions de doses
on en est très loin aujourd'hui avec le
rythme de livraison de deux millions et
demi de doses par mois
il nous faudrait 36 mois si nous
doublons il nous faudrait encore 18 mois
c'est clairement inacceptable il
faudrait que l'on puisse atteindre un
rythme de livraisons de l'ordre de 9 à
10 millions de doses par mois pour
pouvoir faire ce programme complet de
vaccination alors j'en reviens à ma
question pourquoi cette pénurie alors
c'est tenir et elle a plusieurs causes
tout d'abord il ya le problème de
l'organisation de la production et du
soutien que les états ont pu apporter ça
il ya des états comme le royaume uni
comme les etats-unis qui ont beaucoup
aidés les laboratoires et là on voit
qu'il ya peut-être une différence avec
l'union européenne
et puis il ya la question des stratégies
d'achat les etats unis la grande
bretagne ont décidé de payer sans
rechigner
même chose pour israël qui non seulement
accepté de payer un certain surcoût pour
avoir des vaccins mais elle a même
accepté de transférer les données
sanitaires de l'ensemble de ses citoyens
vacciner au laboratoire pfizer
c'est une pratique qui est discutable je
n'en disconviens pas mais qui s'est
répété quand même très efficace alors
et pour ce qui est de l'union européenne
alors la stratégie de l'union européenne
on voit bien qu'elle a été très
différente la stratégie de l'union
européenne ça a été de dire si
voulons pouvoir acheter au meilleur prix
si nous voulons pouvoir peser sur les
laboratoires il faut que l'on achète
groupe et c'était pas idiot d'ailleurs
simplement ça entraîné un niveau d'abord
de lourdeurs bureaucratiques un niveau
de rigidité dans la capacité à passer
des mois ce qui fait que l'union
européenne n'a pu intervenir n'a pu se
positionner en acheteurs qu environ
trois mois après le royaume uni si on
prend simplement le cadre des pays
européens est évidemment ce retard
maintenant il devient cumulatif
on voit très bien que tel que cela
fonctionne aujourd'hui
grosso modo 60 voire 70 % des deux ne
seront pas livrés avant l'été voit avant
la fin du deuxième semestre 2021 donc un
nous auront énormément de mal à pouvoir
atteindre cet objectif de vaccination
des 70% de la population
ça entraîne parfois des conflits
notamment entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni illustration avec le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
oui tout à fait c'est un très bon
exemple stéphanie alors astrazeneca a
été massivement aidées par le
gouvernement britannique
et là si vous voulez ça d'abord permis
astrazeneca de développer ses capacités
mais en échange évidemment le
gouvernement britannique a exigé
d'astrazeneca un effet ce deux contre un
de priorité pour les douze qui sont
produites en grande bretagne et ça c'est
un point extrêmement important
le gouvernement britannique a d'ailleurs
procédé exactement de la même manière
avec vous savez cette start-up
franco-autrichienne val neva qui va elle
aussi qui d'abord est soutenu par le
gouvernement qui lui a payé la
construction d'une nouvelle usine qui va
quand elle l'aura l'homologation pour
son vaccin livrer 100 millions de doses
en priorité en grande-bretagne alors on
voit bien ici le problème de la
stratégie adoptée par l'union européenne
l'union européenne
n'a pas été du tout dans cette stratégie
elle s'est montrée trop rigide trop
lourde
elle n'a pas été capable de saisir toute
une série d'opportunités dont par
exemple le cas de valve neva et le
résultat c'est que aujourd'hui elle est
très largement distancé par le royaume
uni mais alors jacques comment sortir de
la pénurie
alors si vous voulez la meilleure
réponse à la pénurie
c'est évidemment la question de
l'organisation de la production
il n'y a pas de ce point de vue là de
miracle alors le premier point
évidemment c'est qu'il va falloir
encourager les coopérations entre les
différents laboratoires
notez d'ailleurs que ça c'est alors on a
beaucoup parlé de l'accord entre pfizer
et sanofi bon c'est un accord qui porte
plutôt sur l'emballage
ce qu'on appelle le flaconnage mais en
fait c'est déjà un accord qui peut d'une
certaine manière à accélérer la
production il y à un autre accord
important dont on a très peu parlé
c'est l'accord qui était passé entre
astrazeneca et l'institut russe gamaleya
autour de spoutnik 5 et qui pourrait
évidemment ouvrir un des potentialités
une fois que ce footing 5 sera homologué
en europe
donc ça c'est le premier point deuxième
point c'est la question des licences
ouvert et là il faut bien faire une
distinction entre les licences ouvertes
qui sont des licences qui sont rachetés
par les états aux différents
laboratoires et des licences libres qui
serait d'une certaine manière fait que
les gouvernements obligent les
laboratoires à mettre librement en axé
leurs vaccins et la formule de leurs
vaccins alors ce processus des licences
ouvertes il a déjà été historiquement
utilisé en particulier pour les
médicaments contre le sida
on sait que c'est quelque chose qui
marche on sait que c'est quelque chose
qui ne laisse pas fondamentalement les
laboratoires tout en permettant
effectivement une production / très
grande échelle mais malheureusement
c'est un processus qui prend du temps
après il ya une troisième chose hélas si
vous voulez c'est intéressant il
faudrait peut-être que l'on regarde ce
qui a été fait par les états unis
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale parce
que
faut savoir que les états unis ont un
système de planification oui on peut
parler d'une planification qui a été
extrêmement efficace et dans cette
planification en fait chaque fois qu'un
producteur d'avion quand même qu'un
chantier naval les états avaient une
baisse de plan de charge
eh bien on lui transférer la production
d'autres choses c'est que un avionneur
pouvait produire des avions qui avait
été conçu par un autre avionneurs par
exemple des going on a été produit par
lockheed des lockheed ont des produits
par curtis ou pas république etc
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important qui tout comme le choix des
sous-traitants pouvait être d'une
certaine manière désignés par l'état et
là on voit bien que si le commissariat
au plan qui a été recréée en septembre
dernier
ainsi le commissariat au plan avait
quelque chose à faire
ce serait tout à fait cela alors ces
pénuries qui vont durer malheureusement
encore un certain temps
la question qu'on se pose à ce qu'elles
ne vont pas compromettre la reprise
économique
ça malheureusement on peut le craindre
d'ores et déjà l'allemagne a abaissé ses
perspectives de croissance
les perspectives de croissance à la fin
de l'année au mois de décembre dernier
elle était de 5,5 pour cent pour l'année
2000 21
aujourd'hui elles sont ramenées à 3-3 5%
bon c'est quand même une baisse de 2% il
ya le même processus qui est déjà en
cours en france on révise à la baisse
les prévisions pour 2021
plus globalement plus l'épidémie va
durer si vous voulez plus longtemps on
mettra atteindre justement cette
immunité vaccinale donc à vacciner
grosso modo les 70 % de notre population
est plus longtemps l'économie
travaillera au ralenti qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire tout d'abord que
l'europe l'union européenne va prendre
un retard important par rapport à
d'autres pays occidentaux qui eux ont
mieux géré cette question que ce soit
les états unis
que ce soit la grande bretagne mais
surtout qu'elle va accumuler du retard
avec les pays asiatiques qui eux
semblent d'ores et déjà être sorti de
cette phase de crise liée à l'épidémie
de covile 19
et pour conclure jacques à quoi peut-on
s'attendre sur le front des makes alors
à moyen terme
il faut très clairement être optimiste
de nombreux vaccins vont apparaître
il ya évidemment le cas de scouts mx-5
qui est un vaccin en fait beaucoup plus
simple à utiliser que le kaiser et le et
le moderne à il est comparable à l'asra
zeneca sauf qu'il est plus efficace que
la sera délicat ce qui explique
d'ailleurs peut-être l'accord qui a été
signé entre astrazeneca et le
laboratoire gamaleya donc on peut être
plutôt optimiste à moyen terme même si
je ne pense pas que l'on tiendra
l'objectif d'une vaccination de 70% de
la population d'ici le mois de septembre
pour l'instant ça ne me semble
absolument pas possible
par contre le véritable problème qui va
se poser c'est la vaccination dans les
pays en développement ou en voie de
développement dans les pays pauvres et
dans les pays très pauvres parce que si
vous voulez il faut ça il faut
comprendre une chose ça n'a pas de sens
de vouloir atteindre justement cette
situation d'immunité vaccinale dans les
pays développés en laissant le virus se
développe est lui aussi dans les pays
pauvres et très pauvres qui représentent
quand même un énorme ensemble de monde
que ce soit en afrique
que ce soit en amérique latine que ce
soit au moyen-orient que ce soit en asie
centrale et donc de ce point de vue là
c'est quelque chose qui est à la fois
moralement insupportable
tout le monde devrait avoir droit au
vaccin c'est clair mais qui est surtout
inefficace
d'un point de vue sanitaire parce que
cela donnerait la possibilité au virus
de venir nous réinfectés et surtout ça
voudrait dire que le virus aurait
toujours la possibilité de continuer ses
différentes mutations et on verrait à ce
moment là d'autres variés ont des
variants peut-être africains latino
américains
moyen orientaux apparaître régulièrement
donc c'est ça d'une certaine manière le
grand défi des mois qui viennent et ce
sont donc j'avais des choix
véritablement stratégique qui s'imposent
pour sortir de cette pandémie merci à
vous et à la semaine prochaine